there seems to be some questionable
activity going on in the Indianapolis
Colts front office with the whole
Jonathan Taylor situation Taylor request
a trade from the Colts he's one of the
many running backs who aren't satisfied
with their current contracts then Colts
owner Jim irsay decided to release a
pretty bizarre statement he said if I
die tonight and Jonathan Taylor is out
of the league No One's Gonna Miss us
regardless of his comment irsay says he
has no intention of trading Taylor this
is when it starts to get a little sus on
Sunday the Colts were considering
policing Taylor on the non-football
injury list because they claim Taylor
has a back injury Taylor saw this and
went right to Twitter completely denying
that he has this injury one thing that's
really important to know is that if a
player is placed on this NFI list a team
isn't required to pay that player their
salary but if a player is on the pup
list physically unable to perform lists
the players are due their salaries so
for the Colts to consider moving Taylor
to the NFI list for an injury that he
claims he doesn't even have that seems
off